être comparé
des histoires de violences en france
j'ai compris que c'était d'abord retenir
sauvage et explorer cette histoire si
grand représenter tous les autres alors
je vous propose un voyage un voyage au
coeur de l'être par un voyage en veille
voilà
seconde
j'ai traversé la vie on expliqué
jean plus vite avec et gestion
écarté saint
et d'autre part en france
racine de grandeur
mais un jour un jour tout s'est arrêté
vous voulez savoir le premier clic
eh bien eh bien c'est une partie du vide
grande comme ça l'a convié leur maman
d'une petite fille qui a choisi à l'âge
de 5 ans d'arrêter l'école pas trop par
la trop violente qui ne supportait plus
le chantage entre les enfants entrent et
naughty l écran la violence voilà le
deuxième jeu rentrer tranquillement chez
moi il ya quelques mois de cela
un soir un homme
agression
hélas là ne seront pas ça n'arrive pas
qu'aux autres
ça n'arrive pas qu'à son arrivée à voix
haute est pour quelque chose
je retourne là bas comme cela on a juste
envie curling à l'injustice ça devrait
pas exister
c'est encore à régler
il aurait tellement aimé de mal à voir
d'où vient le temps de la prise de
conscience dans la partition
regardons tous dans nos vies la loire de
pouvoir sur l'autre ce qui
rézé c'est la colère qui depuis et puis
la peur aussi entre par l'entourage qui
ne souhaite pas lui vous regardez en
face qui nous est il mort né et j'ai
fini par dire ouais mais toi tu es
quelqu'un de courageux qui est une forte
va pouvoir continuer malgré tout eh bien
non non parce que ce monde n'est pas le
bien une institutrice a bien joué à ma
fille notre société violente c'est pas
falloir que je m'habitue lens est
intense
ce que je veux laisser aux enfants oui
et moi est-ce que je vais et je n'ai pas
peur parce que je n'ai pas eut été
content parce que j'ai accepté d'être
fragile je descends par exemple seront
continues à petit et je reprends
directement les chemins de l'école de la
grande haie pour congeler le n 1 et le
piment aller au delà de l'actualité
nous avons besoin les uns des autres et
j'avais besoin
on a chip déclaré
une déclaration d'interdépendance
pratique aussi je suis un peu fragile je
dénonce aujourd'hui les arts
que nous vivons emprisonnés dans des
stéréotypes qui génère beaucoup de
violence et de souffrance de part et
d'autre alain d'être sensible et à
l'autre d'être un fort rendement de la
conscience parce que c'est de l'action
tourné en extérieur et une seule et de
les différencier
mais les débats en n'excluant pas de
renoncer à l'égalité des chances ou même
de diminuer l'importance du progrès
social mais d'accéder à ce procès le
premier de partage de coopération
générale appartiennent à l'humanité
toute entière
mon sens les instants et nous avons
besoin également des valeurs inscrits
ont passé à l'action matérialiser ses
valeurs et c'est alexandre aulas la
voilà ma conscience trouver la voix
l'alliance inédite et c'est d'abord
question de choix dc oui j'ai les armes
chantier dans lequel je vis mais je ne
bois et aujourd'hui je n'ai qu'un mot à
dire merci merci pour le bruit pour
l'inviter selon la saturation
on commençait à voir delà du regard
commandeur juste après l'amour
alors venez partent à l'aventuré
avoir entendu on dit bien pu se passer
pour que notre être
notre licence
la france
savait elle et en ses chances en selle
dans la course vous lâche pas c'est
quand il dit les petites filles après
leur leçon pour enzo mais aussi la
dernière
nous disons oui je suis vraiment
brillant lors de la broye pour demain à
7 secondes violence la france info mais
elle ne pas s'y soumettre et d'en faire
un exposé de classe en classe politique
et le chantage dans leur titre elles
aussi leur faisait parfois et c'est bien
compréhensible au vu de l'énergie
c'est dommage tout cas chez d'autres il
ya sept ans on n'a pas bien
des enfants dans la vie de maman
découvre que l'on apprend autant et et
par un plus petit et donc moi et moi
aujourd'hui je parle même pas le regarde
pas ce que je veux c'est qu'on a besoin
de voir notre parcours de la ressortir
et et pour tout vous dire cela
et puisqu'il est question de violence
autour de la vie dure mais le voilà
aujourd'hui je suis en vie et
aujourd'hui je sens la body de socle à
un livre avec une amie à les offres des
anthropologues the economist souffrance
beaucoup de violence mais si longtemps
nous enfants
et c'est quand je serai grande je serai
dit enthousiaste retrouvant cette visite
en france il y avait changé j'étais
premier espace deux enfants pas
seulement pour lui mais pour créer votre
manière d'être ensemble
c'est une usine à dreux dans son
ensemble nous avons droit et le tube
dans un canot à l'exercice aux intérêts
de la région
le but de tout ça c'est pas contre la
tranquillité la conscience collective et
je suis aujourd'hui la coopération
n'existe pas la communauté va encore
nous sommes que ça mais alors tu
comprends et si toi de tout ça
alors l'art en bar the reader ou pas
c'est un défi pour l'esprit y est et
c'est aussi un acte d'amour
il est vraiment aujourd'hui de nouvelles
logiques hardy et le voilà travail
reliés réunir associe les énergies
féminine et masculine la course en
sélection et c'est d'abord ce n'est pas
en changeant l'autre je crois que c'est
urgent nous avons tous entendu tout et
j'ai en tant que mal un rôle fondamental
et et bien sûr que parfois encore j'ai
peur mais et j'avais plus l'orgueil de
la robe aussi j'ai l'esprit de besoin
toutes les cordes où il travaillait j'ai
eu l'idée de faire chanter une poussière
des toits dans le coeur des fois les
offres des enfants ayant le retour de
l'espérance et si mon expérience ici on
est à ajoie vivre en énergie en france
je suis et je sais aujourd'hui au plus
proche des 7
ce n'est pas ça qu'on pas ce n'est pas
un autre c'est l'alliance de cette somme
qui permettra dépassé et des grands
alors vous autre chance demain commence
aujourd'hui